c'est un petit garçon papa et qui lui
dit papa et je voudrais savoir pourquoi
mon frère il s'appelle léon alors son
terrible accident
écoute caméra d'or noël les ont donc
c'est un anagramme de bain de noël oui
voilà ok j'ai compris papa lui dit vas-y
si mr mon petit duc des lombards poids
parce que là justin et paf le chien
c'est un parisien qui vient dans le sud
de la france et pour chasser tout hts un
beau fusil
c'était des belles bottes à chapeau
comme ça il va très tôt le matin vers 5
heures du matin ils commencent à chasser
ils passent la journée puis ça arrive et
qui rira de toupie la nuit commence à
tomber une perdrix un peu fatigués
qu'ils veulent
il arriva enfin attrapé la paire d as
perdu ton sur le toit d'une ferme iran
qui sonne on s'est dit bonjour là je
suis majeur j'ai tué à un oiseau et elle
est tombée dans votre sac je voudrais le
récupérer le fermier le paysan et alain
rousset a c'est impossible parce que
c'est la loi la paire d'être tombé sur
mon terrain donc a perdu ma partie et où
il me comprenait je viens de paris je
suis une exprès pour pourchasser je sais
c'est tout l'intérêt je suis débutant
maintenant je tiens absolument à rentrer
avec avec le gibier quoi alors s'il vous
plaît je n ai rien à faire [ __ ] pas
perdu c'est la loi et sur mon terrain et
sur le toit et la perdrix et on peut
s'arranger je vous donne de l'argent ce
que voulait faire peut-être qu'on peut
s'arrêter si vous voulez on va faire et
je sais quoi le jeu m'a fait région à se
mettre en face de l'autre mais bon on a
écarté jamais plus à se mettre un gros
coup de pierres entre hommes n'en ont
pas dire les couilles et à ce moment là
mais celui qui craque le premier gagnant
perdrix gimont met d'accord et ses mots
mais je commence à écarter jambe brisée
car ces gens aimés gros coup de gueule
culpa hier
il suffit se relève difficilement
c'est quoi finalement tu as gagné pratta
perdrix voici sur tout ça c'est bouder
quand il était petit valoir son papa le
discount papa c'est quoi le truc qu'on a
sur la tête son père ludiques ou deux ça
c'est la charia
quand on marche dans le désert c'est
bien contre le soleil comme ça on a pas
d'inflation d'aquagym et papa promet une
grande ronde 10 as une djellaba quand on
est dans le désert tu vas pas beaucoup
sué avec ça ne m'est pas pourquoi on a
des chaussures bizarre je ne sais pas
d'exception bizarre ça c'est des
babouches
quand tu marches dans le désert le sable
y rentre pas on peut de fer indiens son
père mais papa puisse couler si bien
équipé pour le désert qu'est ce qu'on
fois j'en paye
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
là vraiment on a du lourd à l'ats avoir
d'accord c'est le fils de jean-marie qui
dit qui dit papa de smart à meyrin il
dit papa comment on fait les bébés et là
il dit bon c'est très simple c'est à
dire papa il mais il met la petite
graine dans le chouchou de maman à et
après bas prix pousse avec sa grosse
[ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
à
ce soir là alors c'est l histoire
préférée de singe gainsbourg c'est un
tipi pas jeunes alors la blague je t'ai
laissé finir ta blague malgré ton accent
incompréhension j'avais un mug habite en
face qui rôdent de temps en temps dans
l'émission dont qui va acheter des
habits en sang
[Applaudissements]
c'est la guerre j'ai 30 ans de carrière
j'ai pas envie de ça entente avec je
vais acheter des pompes dans la boutique
et puis la ligue pour essayer ce modèle
là il retient ses pompes et là il ya un
espèce de puanteur à couper au couteau
qui remplit la boutique et la vendeuse
s'évanouit tellement ça pue et non dans
l'époque littéralement il yal'autre
vendeuse qui voient ça elle dit tiens
vatra franchir et où je m'occupe de
monsieur est là elle est envahie par
l'odeur est là elle vomit devant le mec
elle vomit le patron arrive et dit
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est bien ça
monsieur qu'est un peu contre laissez
moi je vais gérer et le patron de
monsieur oui vous voulez essayer ça et
là l'odeur lui montent aux naseaux et il
y écouter partir des chaussures
maintenant par thomas temps jeu je vous
les offre porter ma tenue ans et c'est
mon jour de bonté ses parts et c'est à
vous c'est gratuit
vite partez santé de monsieur ok ok il
sort et au moment de s'en tirer sur avis
sur la porte il dit et si je peux être
une boîte de cirage
ouais
c'est
cernés dans les absurdes ces pseudos
domingo et qui rencontrent luciano
pavarotti ces deux ténors avec un mégot
que ça un dialogue qui disent avoir dit
ça va aider à la semaine dernière j'ai
chanté à milan cinquante mille personnes
à un moment pendant que j'ai chanté il
ya une statue de la vierge qu'elle a
s'est mise à pleurer de la pierre tout
le monde à genoux miraculeux dis toi m'a
dit moi je t'ai are you il ya trois
jours
850 et 1000 personnes un moment pendant
que je chantais ya j'ai jugé qu'il est
seul à croire le coq au vin doux les dix
ans nous monter sur la scène j'ai pas
comme l'autre qu'on a qui a fait pleurer
ma mère
[Applaudissements]
bouzou
on voit se débine pour jeu vraiment
ludivine et genre et du mag c'est un
braqueur qui monte dans un bus et qui
tout le monde les mains en l'air sauf
l'arabe et la vie de regarder you [ __ ]
tu m'as fait peur le christ et les
contrôleurs aller
il est sûr c'est qu'un bowling cac
volley on aime bien c'est le petit petit
génie du village et des gentils et elle
n'est pas un peu folle qui est un peu
coincé comme un [ __ ] puis qui sait
mais on aime bien que voler très fort ce
qui s'est trouvé des cèpes
il sait où sont les cèpes et d'ailleurs
il de la forêt est en train de chercher
les cp live il pousse un petit buisson
et la banlieue
l énorme c'est que j'ai jamais vu comme
ça au moins ça qu'ils ont jamais vu çà
et là le cep tu commences à parler qu'un
gaulin je suis le set magique tu ne me
cueille pas je vais exaucé 3 2 tv oh mon
dieu mais c'est la chance de ma vie
c'est léchage de ma vie bien sûr que je
te paye pas et bien c'est peu magique
je voudrais avoir m'amène comme l'autre
de l'entente doté du bas moralement fou
si j'ai le mec et va chez le médecin
super bien et il a ses médecins il un
couteau de planté dans le dos il ait
chez lui sain directeur
qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire pour moi
m'a dit rien parce que dès que t il et
17h55
et moi je ferme à six heures prise il
enfin a dit l'acteur n'est pas me
laisser comme ça qu'a couteau dans le
dos dimon d'accord passe derrière le mec
il prends le couteau il l'arraché dit
tournée vous le mets qui se tourne
il est plein dans l'oeil j'ai dit 2 kg
sujet m'a dit vous allez voir mon
collègue
enfin si les ophtalmos lui ferment à 19
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est un première année de
médecine
il ya de grands médecins réunis toute sa
classe 30 élèves
et là c'est le jour j faut y aller là ya
un cadavre et là ils font une autopsie
hélas les gamins ils ont les ans vingt
balais ils sont un peu impressionnés et
lit pour faire médecine
je sais pas si vous arriverez au bout il
ya sept ans plus si vous faite une
spécialité mais pour faire métier il
faut deux grandes qualités premières
grandes qualités il faut pas être
dégoûté et l'arrivée de son doigt dans
le cul du cadavre il suce son doigt et à
30 élèves son nom est favori mais
maintenant c'est à votre tour
tous les élèves le font tous et à la fin
il dit deuxième grande qualité c'est
l'observation
moi j'ai mis le majeur et je suçais
l'index
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l'eau
d'abord
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est une femme qui tombe par la
fenêtre du 40e étage voilà de son
immeuble
donc elle hurle elle arrive au niveau du
30e étage là y'a un mec qui l'attrapent
et qui lui dit tu ce qu'a dit mon sens
ça va pas non il l'a lâche donc elle
continue sa chute lure la lure au 20ème
étage à la rive il ya un mec qui
l'attrapent il tient la main nue this
uber si parfois vous êtes dégueulasse
des malades
il lâche avec continuer à hurler larivot
didier ménages
il ya un mec qui la trup elle le regarda
lui dit je suis jamais je fais où ils
lui disent à loeb
[Applaudissements]
g
excuse moi je viens d'arriver
tu serais pas la femme de jean marie
bigard
hubert alors je suis miller moi je peux
pas rester c'est bénichou mon pote simo
il se lance dans la vente de cloud il
apporte son coin de l'appel son petit
doute me viennent à toi tu es fort en
publicité fais-moi une pub de ouf pour
vendre mais cloud loti réfléchi midi
demain tu vas voir dans tout les rues de
paris
tu vas voir ta put il sort bénéchou il
sort et voit la pub qui lui a fait cas
par trois jésus dit jésus cloué par les
clous bénichou lendemain ils arrivent
ils regardent n'a pu bien que lacroix a
pas jésus écrit à ce n'avait été cloué
par benichou
[Applaudissements]